let's go uh let's go next to Brandon
from North Carolina Brandon welcome to
the program
Brandon from North Carolina you are
muting yourself right now it's a
self-mute as soon as you unmute yourself
you'll be able to hear me yes I can
hello David nice to talk to you likewise
let's go Brandon uh so uh yeah I just
was wanting to ask you uh well Brandon
Brandon wait a second you're shot out of
a cannon can you move the microphone a
little bit further from your mouth
of course sorry
that's better that's smoother I like
that okay is that okay so you can hear
me better yeah much better okay uh so uh
yeah I was wanting to ask you so what's
your sit uh mind uh think about
um the whole Alvin brag not wanting to
prosecute
Trump on uh his finances I have not read
much about that is Alvin Bragg was that
the New York D.A that it led to two
investigators quitting because they were
like this is going nowhere our work is
pointless yeah uh he's the southern
district ah I see it here yeah listen at
the time when that was that was news
it seemed to me that it was obvious that
that was going on to some degree we've
been saying for a while it seems that
nobody wants to be the first to
prosecute Trump and we'll see if federal
charges end up being the first thing
here's my view on it if the facts say
that a prosecution is correct not
Prosecuting is a cop-out and it's
cowardly now that being said that being
said
we only want to bring charges against
anyone random people or a former
president when the evidence supports it
so it's not prosecute Trump because I
think Trump's a terrible president it's
if that's what the evidence says should
be done it should be done and not doing
it is a real problem
he absolutely
all right how are things otherwise in
North Carolina uh uh pretty good other
than uh
besides our words and infrastructure and
stuff pretty good but um other than that
um pretty good uh Beasley's ahead and
also as long as we don't elect but
what's wrong with the roads is it like
potholes or what yeah potholes like I'll
which rows are pretty much just like
crumbling you can literally just see the
wear on them like it's just you can just
see the the wear and tear on them it's
pretty bad that's horrible that's
horrible all right Brandon well thank
you for the call thank you very much
take it easy David YouTube there's
Brandon from North Carolina let's take a
quick break and get right back to the
callers if you're holding on to talk to
me hold on just a moment longer because
we're going right back to the phones